in trunk going after Washington state
leaders for not breaking up the cop free
zone in Seattle take a look we have a
governor's as stiff and we have a mayor
who said oh this is going to be a love
fest but they don't do the job I'll do
the job radical left press doesn't cover
it they're acting like nothing happened
no the problem with what happened in
Seattle is it spreads and all of a
sudden they'll say let's do some other
city and let's do another one Greg let
me begin with you why do you think the
president sees this as a threat to
public safety well because there's no
law and order this is I mean what we're
seeing is an experiment in infantile
behavior there are humans on this planet
who can't value something until it's
taken from them so they have no idea
like how to make anything where does
food come from electricity it just comes
through the walls so they don't realize
this until it's all gone it's kind of
like when you're in a relationship and
somebody dumps you and then you go I
didn't know what I had was so special so
now the real the irony is they're
realizing the importance of boundaries
they're building walls they're realizing
that law they're setting up their own
law and order and it's actually kind of
hyper violent they're even doing some
kind of Jim Crow crap where they're
separating races because that's
ultimately what happens with leftism
they don't they're trying to figure a
date and figure out but maybe commerce
might help them so now they're actually
figuring out that having no structure is
leading to fascism this is the Lord of
the Flies situation and I kind of I I
think the good news is it's devolving
fast at some point they're gonna run out
everything and then you're going to
return to the population and annoy the
rest of us but maybe they might just be
a little bit wiser although I doubt it
all right Dana why do you think there's
a need for the federal government to
intervene if you do think that because
the state and local officials as the
president indicated don't see any threat
don't see any problem in terms of Public
Safety
so I was thinking about this today
because I part of me feels like if they
all think this is some big festival and
a big party and the local people are
like oh well you know if that's how they
really feel
then perhaps letting that experiment go
on is okay however you saw the police
chief from there being very honest and
blunt and saying that she knows what's
going to happen she actually loves her
city she does she didn't want to abandon
the precinct she thinks this is bad into
president Trump's point you've already
seen other people try to do something
similar like in Nashville of all places
so his point is that it could spread is
a good one as well
one of my problems with these guys is
that they're so inept they can't even
decide what to call themselves it was
Chaz and now it's chop but they can't
decide what the O stands for or the P so
now they're super confused plus they
take conventional security to help them
deal with their issues they actually had
to call in a real fire truck to help
them put out an actual dumpster fire
then someone took a bad drug then they
had to call an actual ambulance and then
you have the fact that they they're
playing dodge ball in the street what
happens when somebody's eye gets taken
out by one of those things I mean
somebody has to figure out but basically
one nobody has parents nobody has
parents you mean the parents should call
him home Dena huh yeah they pilot one
let me just ask you Jesse I mentioned
last week guys I still am stumped by
this you know that in 2016 I think it
was there was a you know a group of
gun-toting people took over a federal
wildlife reserve in Oregon you know it
disrupted federal government workers and
there was no outcry from the far right
but outcry over this what's the
difference I don't remember much about
the story I do remember that they had
some sort of what they thought was valid
legal claim to the land or the property
and it was like what some cabin out in
the middle of nowhere okay this is six
city blocks in the middle of a hustling
bustling metropolitan area with small
businesses right there
so a little bit different but neither
here nor there god forbid one if this
country is ever invaded because Seattle
would be the first city to fall I mean
is the mayor French because she's
surrendered before there was even shots
fired think about it
she has allowed a bunch of like
hitchhikers and radical ideologues to
come into her city and basically build a
fort like like the twelve-year-old would
build a fort in your house and start
making demands and now she's really
poorly negotiating with them and no one
knows what's going on if you think about
it like this I think I know why
number one they had to change their name
Dana because Chaz was the name of Will
Ferrell's character in wedding crashers
that was the guy that lived in the horns
basement and wore pajamas all day
remember mom the meatloaf right so they
thought that was maybe too close to home
so they changed it to chop which I guess
is sturdier and is going to send shivers
up the spine of this mayor but I think
it's because the mayor and the governor
Inslee up there they're baby boomers and
they kind of their characters were
forged in the 60s protest era so they
like this fight the power fight the
police fight the system peace love and
all that deal and they have a soft spot
for Chaz and they're gonna give Chaz
like they did and Tifa and the litter is
a nice soft off-ramp out of this thing
because deep down they want to give this
group a room to be radical because
they're kind of living vicariously
through this thing it's the new
generation but they're just not treating
them the same because if there were
those Bundy people who whoever Wan was
talking about in the city they'd have
snipers on the roof ready for the kill
shot all right Dagan is this about
President Trump trying to paint all
protesters as terrorists and Tifa a
threat without any evidence and even no
evidence of any wrongdoing on the part
of these young people experimenting with
the Summer of Love in Seattle yeah they
should have stuck with the name Chaz if
it was all about the love and the
kumbaya cuz chairs sounds like
I don't know a new flavor of gelato or
maybe yeah interpretive dance that they
only do with their toes it's actually
about Trump it'd be caught with what the
governor and the mayor are doing that's
why they're trying to make it about
Trump and essentially egg him on where
in the hell is the governor where's Jay
Ensley because again it's the fifth
amendment right and obligation to
provide some semblance of law and order
for the state and you know what this is
Seattle is the Seattle itself and the
surrounding area is the hub for large
tech companies Amazon's based their
Starbucks Costco Microsoft is nearby why
aren't those tech executives on the
ring-a-ding-ding with the governor tell
him to get his act together and get rid
of these layabouts and put them back to
work